[Musique]
daż bonjour Je vous interview
aujourd'hui pour un site internet qui
s'appelle sview nous aurions aimé avoir
votre point de vue sur des questions
concernant le
numérique qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur le CSA et ses nouveaux pouvoirs
d'abord il les a pas encore ses nouveaux
pouvoirs pour le moment il est en train
de se tirer sur la nouille pour les
obtenir mais il les a
pas d'un autre côté ça fait 18 ans que
le CSA essaie d'avoir des pouvoirs sur
le sur le net et qu' pour le moment il n
arrive pas le Gouvernement est favorable
mais tous les gouvernements depuis 18
ans il étaient favorable donc c'est
c'est moins à que ça n l'air
euh c'est inquiétant quand même parce
que c'est une source de problème et
c'est pour ça que ça fait 18 ans qu'on
s'y oppose pour comprendre la question
qui est au fond il
faut en fait il faut voir ça de manière
très simple le pouvoir a une le CSA a un
certain pouvoir une certaine légitimité
à réguler les contenus en matière de
hertiien pour des raisons
techniques qu'il y a un très faible
nombre de chaînes possibles en hertien
il peut pas y avoir 30 millions de
chaînes de télévision en France pas sur
du rtien pas sur les
réseaux
anciens et c'est pour ça que le CSA
régule et c'est pour ça que le CSA a un
certain pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
euh comme c'est souvent expliqué on dit
que les fréquences sont attribuées
gratuitement aux chaînes de télévision
en dehors du fait du ouais non mais là
là le CSA CSA c'est plus c'est plus du
temp du radio amateur qui régul les non
mais d'ailleurs les radio amateurs sont
pas sont pas régulés par le CSA les
radio amateurs c'est les attributions de
fréquence par l'ARC qui ne fait que de
la technique et qui touche jamais au
contenu tout le CSA fait fait de la
régulation de contenu parce que il y a
pas beaucoup de fréquence et qu'elles
sont attribué gratuitement aux chaînes
et le CSA pour ne pas disparaître
aimerait faire de la régulation de
contenu sur Internet c'est ça le fond de
la question et régulation de contenu sur
Internet il y a pas de bonne raison de
le faire c'est aussi simple que ça le
CSA fait de la régulation de contenu à
la télé parce que il y a pas assez de
fréquence on peut pas faire de la
régulation de contenu sur Internet donc
pour les mêmes raisons parce que il y a
assez de fréquence on peut ouvrir un
nombre quelconque de chaînes de
télévision ou le site web sur Internet
et c'est le le la clé de voûte pour
comprendre l'enjeu est là après
comprendre tout ce que le CSA pourra
faire comme connerie sur Internet c'est
sans borne c'est sans
borne la labellisation est un début
c'est facile c'est s sans impact majeur
immédiat c'est un problème quand même
selon quel morale le CSA va labéliser
quoi c'est ils vont décider de ce qu'il
faut pas montrer aux enfants donc si la
morale change
qu'est-ce qu'on fait si la morale change
ça c'est une question qui est compliqué
quand les seront au pouvoir on aura un
État fasciste point faut faire
avec pour moi c'est justement parce
qu'on donne trop de pouvoir à des
endroits où il doit pas y en avoir que
le que le mode de gouvernement change
faut pas se demander que fera le
prochain nazi au pouvoir avec les outils
qu'on lui a fait faut se demander en
quoi les outils qu'on fait nous prép é
totalitaire on peut très bien avoir un
état totalitaire
sans sans sans forcément avoir les fchau
au pouvoir l'État totalitaire se prépare
déjà il est déjà en
cours on a des on a des éléments dans le
dans le mode de fonctionnement actuel
qui sont proches du totalitarisme les
exemples les pouvoirs qu'on ve donner au
CSA c'est un très bon exemple le la
liberté d'expression est une liberté
cardinale c'est un des éléments clés
d'une structure d'État démocratique on
peut pas avoir un système démocratique
s'il y a pas de liberté d'expression que
c'est la liberté qui permet de dénoncer
tous les abus donc qui permet de
protéger toutes les autres
libertés à partir du moment où on donne
le pouvoir à un organe
administratif de réguler la liberté
d'expression on commence c'est un pas
vers la sortie d'un modèle démocratique
et d' État de
droit on retrouve exactement les mêmes
au sur par exemple les débats autour de
la liberté
d'expressionour de la neutralité du Net
la liberté d'expression en étant un
volet à partir du moment où on autorise
les opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent
sur le réseau en fait on les autorise à
modifier la société on les autorise à
modifier la façon dont les gens
interagissent entre eux et donc à
avoir à imprimer leur marque sur la
société qui vient avec c'est exactement
ce que fait Apple avecale Store
l'App Store de
d'iOS c'est une façon de déformer la
société ça c'est c'est r captif non ça
rendre captif c'est un c'est la méthode
c'est pas le c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est que quand tu
quand tu as la main mise de d'un
organisme sur les contenus disponibles
tu as une morale qui s'applique et tu as
une vision du monde qui s'applique et
toute vision du monde divergente devient
impossible mais est-ce que tu penses pas
que le le mode opératoire traduit le
fond du raisonnement non je pense que
c'est le contraire je pense que c'est
parce qu'on met en place ce type d'outil
qu'on a une société qui bascule
doucement vers une espèce de
totalitarisme soft c'est c'est vraiment
je crois pas que c'est parce que nos
dirigeants ont des visés totalitaires
qui mettent en place des outils de
régime totalitaire je pense que c'est
parce que on injecte dans le régime des
outils totalitaires que le régime a un
comportement de plus en plus totalitaire
est-ce est-ce que tu peux est-ce que tu
peux un petit peu nous je te tutoi
est-ce que tu peux un petit peu nous
nous développer le concept d'Internet à
péage et de la on va dire la neutralité
du Net les opérateurs veulent faire quoi
les conséquences en quelques mots les
conséquences de tout ça ben ce que les
opérateurs veulent faire c'est assez
simple c'est une lecture à courte vue
ils veulent récupérer un tout petit peu
d'argent de plus que ce qu'il récupère
déjà en fait ça part d'unun constat
qui est enfantin un opérateur c'est
quelqu'un qui fait des travaux
d'infrastructure qui construit des
réseaux qui investit des centaines de
millions pour poser de la fibre optique
ou du câble ou et cetera et CETA et
cetera et qui en échange de ça gagne 30
€ par mois
d'abonnement un site de rencontre c'est
un site web qui fait presque rien qui
fournit tris pages une base de données
et quelques outils de recherche et qui
vend ses abonnements 30 € par mois tu
penses que c'est légitime c'est qu'il
faut c'est pas le problème que ce soit
légitime ou pas c'est qu'il y en a un
des deux qui est très jaloux un des deux
qui qui s'est démené la Coan pour gagner
30 € l'autre qui a fait presque rien qui
en fait pour 30 € te vends tes photos
parce que le seul contenu qui a à vendre
mythique par exemple ce sont les profils
que les gens ont mis dessus le seul truc
que Monsieur Facebook a à vendre c'est
ce que tu lui as donné il a rien
fabriqué lui j'ouvre une parenthèse
parle-moi un petit peu de ton donne-moi
un petit peu ta ton mode de perception
sur le Big Data c'est autre chose je le
garde sous le cou celui-là allez alle
pour tout à l'heure
le donc en fait le la neutralité du net
ce sont les opérateurs qui cherch à
récupérer une part de l'argent que se
font les gens qui développent les
services sur Internet il parle de l'idée
moi j'ai payé toute l'infrastructure lui
il a payé rien du tout et il fait autant
d'argent que moi et c'est pas juste mais
je sais pas si c'est juste ou pas ce que
je sais c'est
que c'est dangereux c'est que que en
fait comment ils veulent traiter ça ils
veulent faire en sorte de
euh en fait si tu décris leur monde
idéal tu as pris un abonnement chez
Pinin Télécom et du coup tu as un très
bel accès vers Pinpin VOD et par contre
quand tu veux accéder à Netflix ou à
Youtube c'est lent ça rame ça marche pas
bien et donc du coup tous les films que
tu achètes c'est chez Pinpin VOD tous
les sites porno que tu regardes c'est
ceux de Pinpin porno et cetera et cetera
et cetera et donc tout ce que tu
consommes tu achètes des livres chez
Pinin librairie surtout pas chez Amazon
donc le modèle de business donc leur
modèle de business c'est de tenir dans
une bulle fermée et de de fabriquer
cette bulle fermée en faisant de la
priorisation sur le
réseau ce qu'on défend nous c'est le
fait que en faisant ça tu déformes le
réseau et tu déformes la vision que les
gens ont du monde c'est tu n'as plus
d'accès à une
information de manière neutre bêtement
quand tu es sur le réseau Internet de
manière normale tu vas voir n'importe
quel site web tu te demandes jamais chez
qui il est hébergé tu te demandes jamais
comment il est raccordé au réseau tu as
accès à tout Internet nê pas juste au
bout que l'opérateur a voulu te montrer
il y a 15 ans ils essayaient de faire ça
avec des portails captifs il faisaient
ça avec des portails tu arrivait sur le
portail Orange où tu avais les news la
météo machin et l'objectif était que tu
n'en sortes jamais qu'est-ce que tu
penses qu'est-ce que ça va créer chez
les chez les fournisseurs d'accès
associatif les fournisseurs d'accès
Internet
associatif mais en fait nous on est les
moins mis en danger là-dessus parce que
euh nos abonnés ils ont accès à tout ils
y ont accès comme ils veulent si ça
coûte cher en bande passante il pay cher
en abonnement on se pose pas de question
très compliqué c'est nous on est pas on
n pas tellement la question làdessus on
est plutôt la réponse on est plutôt la
bonne réponse à la question
mais le fond du problème c'est que tu
déformes tu déforme la perception les
gens ont du
monde tu crées une société déformée en
fait tu recrées un mécanisme aussi
pervers et aussi mauais la
télévisionas recréé TF1 sauf que ça
s'appelle pas TF1 ça s'appelle orange
quand tu
vois l'aspect télévision ça devient
dur donc développement un petit peu ton
ton point de vue sur la Big Data alors
les questions de Big
Data bon il y a tout un tas de de
questions làdedans qui sont extrêmement
intéressantes mais sont pas sur mon
sujet qui sont les questions de business
et comment on peut faire du business
avec du Big
Data il y a plein de gens qui qui les
développent beaucoup mieux que moi et
c'est le sujet moi me passionne pas je
suis pas entrepreneur mon ambition dans
la vie n'est pas d'être milliardaire
tout va bien
euh
le le sujet pour moi c'est de comprendre
à quel moment ça te touche toi en tant
qu'humain et quel est le rôle que joue
l'utilisateur
là-dedans est-ce que l'humain qui est au
milieu de tout ça il est juste la
marchandise il ferme bien sa gueule où
est-ce qu'il est quelque chose de plus
central si qu'il reste avant tout
citoyen pensant actif acteur de sa vie
autonome et adulte et c'est c'est en
fait une vraie question que tu peux déjà
poser sur des sites plus
simples je peux te la formuler de
manière enfantine qui est propriétaire
de ce que tu as mis sur facebook toi
forcément toi toutes les autres réponses
sont dangereuses toutes les autres
réponses disent que tu n'es plus adulte
que tu n'es pas libre de relire tes
anciennes conversations que tu n'es pas
libre de retirer les contenus que tu as
mis autrefois que tu n'es pas libre de
partir et pour moi il y a un élément
central dans les questions sur les
données personnelles et sur le Big
datata qui est comment tu reprends tes
billes ça le lieu touristique faut
assumer en interview c'est curieux des
fois c'est agréable pour la rtine
le la question est de savoir en fait
pour moi ça revient quasiment à la
question de la portabilité des données a
un système Big Data quelconque j'ai pas
de problème avec du moment que moi
humain acteur de ma vie je peux décider
de prendre mes billes et de partir ça
peut être effacer les données ça peut
être juste dire je les emmène on parle
d'un lieu touristique est-ce que tu
penses que les gens qui viennent de
passer la population les jeunes sont
conscients de ces enjeux de société ça
vient ça vient ça vient
venir ça vient plus vite qu'on croit et
ça vient par les gamins ça vient par les
gamins il comprennent très
vite écoute moi j'ai pas l'impression je
te donne un exemple très très simple le
résultat de l'affaire Snowden c'est que
les gens ont compris ce que c'était que
les mé là sur le téléphone ils
comprennent que ça existe et quand tu
leur parles ils t'écoute quand tu leur
en parlais il y a 3 ans il t'écoutait
pas quand tu leur dis euh ton téléphone
envoie sur le sur le réseau des infos de
géolocalisation en permanence ils
comprennent assez vite que oui d'accord
les opérateurs enregistre ça ah en fait
ils ignoraient qu'on qu' l'opérateur
avait cette info et certains opérateurs
ont des des rapports consangin avec les
services de renseignement oui mais c'est
toujours les services de renseignement
ont des rapports consanguins avec les
grands groupes c'est d'accord
[Musique]
le gouvernement et copain avec les
patrons du CAC 40 c'est pas une grande
nouveauté quoi c'est pas très innovant
Ctait vrais s de B si tu veux RTF oh ça
c pire pire dis qu'on VI à la télévision
donc
mais si tu veux pour moi la proche de ce
cl je te donne quelques exemples très bê
c'est tu devrais pouvoir sur Facebook en
quelqu clic télécharger un fichier qui
contient toute ta page facebook tout ce
que tu as dit ce que les gens t'ont dit
ce que tu as fait tout l'historique ton
carnet d'adresse tes contacts tes
copains ce qu' ont ce que tu as dit avec
eux enfin tout ce que Facebook a sur ton
compte mais ça c'est possible non al
l'URE actuelle tu peux pas le récupérer
c'est le seul mec qui a réussi à le
récupérer il s'est mangé des années de
procès pour y arriver et il a eu le
droit d'avoir le tout sous forme d'un
PDF c'est inutilisable tu devrais
pouvoir récupérer tout ça sous un format
utilisable d'accord je te donne un autre
exemple ton opérateur de téléphonie a
les données de géolocalisation sur ton
mobile et ben sur le le de site client
qui te donne où il met tes factures il
te met tes factures détaillé qui tu as
appelé combien de temps tu as parlé avec
ta mémé hier tout ça il le met tu peux
même télécharger les messages qui sur ta
voix vocale pourquoi à côté il y a pas
les données qu'il a sur toi disant bah
voilà ça c'est les traces qu'on a de
géolocalisation il y a pas de secret tu
savais très bien où tu étais
mais le fait de savoir le fait de savoir
qu'ils ont les données ferait de toi un
acteur beaucoup plus conscient de ce que
tu es de ce que tu fais de ce qu'il sait
sur toi du fait qu'il peut il peut
donner ça à la police sur toi ou il peut
don ça à quelqu'un d'autre ou il y a
peut-être un copain qui travaille qui
pour reev Norte quel système là-bas peut
avoir accès aux informations d'accord
donc ça te permet de savoir ce qui
existe et à partir du moment où tu
saisorte qui accrédité peut-être non je
t'assure en pratique le mec qui route
sur l'ordinateur il fait ce qu'il veut
accréditer ou pas c'est tuas tu as deux
personnes pour un pouvoir infini dans
une boîte tu as l'actionnaire et tu as
l'administ C de là ils font ce qu'ils
veulent revenons un peu sur les jeunes
est-ce que tu les jeunes de plus en plus
comprnent
qu'il laissent des traces comprennent à
peu près quelle trace il laissent et il
suffirait que tu mettes en fait si tu
leur laisses accès aux données qu'ils
ont générer et que tu rends ces données
portables don qu' puissent les emmener
les utiliser ailleurs alors ils vont
très bien comprendre dans quel monde ils
sont ils vont très bien comprendre ce
qu'ils font je pense qu'on verra même
apparaître des formes d'art perverses
qui consistent à se comporter de manière
à avoir laissé une trace qui soit
jolie c'est que tu non mais c'est super
rigolo après comme idée c'est tu te
promènes avec comme objectif que la
trace laissée par ton
téléphonexique face un joli dessin
face un parcours historique dans Paris
face je pas ça
dessinejàion as plein de trucs qui
apparaissent à partir de ça d'accord je
voudrais te poser une autre petite
question concernant la
jeunesse est-ce que tu penses que les
jeune génération ce sont un peu plus
jeune que nous que toi
on un enseignement suffisamment
pertinent sur les questions numériques
depuis l'école estce que depuis l'école
on les sensibilise correctement à tes
yeux à ces questions là non et la
question est pas numérique la question
est quoi alors la question est pas
numérique c'est pas au numérique qu'
faut les sensibiliser c'est à la société
du réseau c'est à la société qui
construit je dis souvent apprendre la
programmation au gamin ouais autant
qu'on leur apprend l'électronique si tu
veux c'est c'est pratique c'est bien
d'avoir une petite culture générale de
comprendre les bases de voir un peu près
ce que ça fait de pas croire à la magie
quoi de comprendre que ça existe mais
c'est pas
important le grand apport d'internet
c'est qu'Internet permet aux gens
d'écrire internet permet aux gens de
s'exprimer créer
ouais créer tu prends l'approche
artistique tout de suite mais non juste
écrire ce que tu en fait ce que ce que
tu écris sur ton sur ton ton facebook ou
ton blogueur ou ton
Twitter ou sur ta page que tu héberges
sur sur ta machine à la maison ce que tu
écris sera lu par potentiellement
n'importe qui sur internet ça existait
pas
avant ma mère quand elle écrivait elle
écrivait une lettre à quelqu'un c'était
précis C cblé elle a jamais écrit dans
la presse en train de me décrire une
société beaucoup plus horizontal je suis
en train de te décrire une société dans
laquelle les gens s'expriment en public
et ils sont pas formés à ça pour moi
l'enseignement central autour du
numérique tout ça c'est vraiment la
partie
euh expliquer apprendre aux enfants à
s'exprimer en public c'est apprendre
euh c'est pour moi les questions autour
d'Internet c'est pas pour les profs de
maths ou pour les profs de sciences
c'est pour les profs de français c'est
pour les profs de
philo il faut apprendre au gamin non pas
à lire et écrire comme il comme onit au
19e siècle mais à lire et écrire pour
être lu et écrire en public écrire pour
publier c'est ça c'est un enseignement
très particulier du numérique est-ce que
tu penses que les profs trouve
effffectivement avec ça vient une
société qui est horizontale mais ça la
société horizontale les gamins s font
très bien tout seul ils ont pas besoin
qu'on les forme d'accord est-ce que tu
penses que l'éducation nationale est-ce
que tu as un message à faire passer à
l'éducation nationale est-ce que tu as
déjà essayé de de faire passer un
message à l'éducation nationale dans ce
sens non moi je bosse très peu sur les
questions d'éducation parce qu'elles
sont compliquées parce qu'elles suppose
de
connaître en fait faut connaître les
rouages faut savoir à qui all est parler
je connais pas du tout ce monde là le
mec qui fait ça très bien c'est si tu
veux poser des questions sur le
l'éducation et le numérique c'est Michel
Guillou qu' faut que tu rencontes ouais
c'est le mec qui qui connaît le sujet
qui sait ce qu'il fait qui et tu verras
il est rigolo comme tout très bien je te
recommande ch Mo donc on va passer aux
préconisations si tu avais un conseil
immortel à laisser sur la toile aux
jeunes générations alle peut-être même
deux
conseils gardez Internet et gardez-le
ouvert vraiment les deux de de éléments
clés comment comment ça on
trouvera c'est facile c'est comme
toujours c'est tu tu repères qui a du
pouvoir et veut l'accroître et le
conserver et lui il faut faut le taper
et taper c'est grand mot ouais tu peux
le taper avec une loi si ça suffit
d'accord quand ça suffit pas faut sortir
plus
gros mais c'est c'est exactement
comme protéger la liberté d'expression
c'est empêcher queil y ait tous les
journaux au mains de TR pouvoirs c'est
empêcher que il y ait tous les partis
aux mains de trois lobby c'est empêché
que ça c'est fait en sorte que le jeu
reste ouvert et internet est un outil
qui permet d'ouvrir le jeu et donc
protéger internet pour ce qu'il est pas
les réseaux pas le numérique le
numérique ça sert à rien numérique c'est
du bullshit cétais en train de me filmer
en numérique là tu m'aurais filmé en
argentie c'était pareil si au lieu de me
filmer tu avais noté mes propos pour les
recopier sur un papier c'était pareil ça
avait la même valeur
peut-être pas la même rapidité ouais ça
c'est même pas sûr ta mère quand elle
écrivait à sa copine ça va-être une
semaine à cheval non bah ouais ça
mettait peut-être une semaine à cheval
d'un autre côté le était plus plus
condensé du coup plus structuré du coup
plus réfléchi avec moins de blanc
avec c'est pas pareil tu ressors
n'importe quel bouquin du du 17e siècle
en matière de politique c'est autrement
plus dense que les merdes qui pondent
aujourd'hui et c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont plus intellig c'est juste ils
réfléchissent plus avant d'écrire est-ce
que tu as des sites à conseiller pour
s'informer est-ce que tu as des méthodes
est-ce que tu as des des choses comme
çacarcell pour s'informer C assez
compliqué pour comprendre les combats
politiques tu as des infos sur la
quadrature qui sont qui sont bien
faites pour essayer de comprendre le
monde qui vient il y a pas grandchose
aujourd'hui il y a il y a quelques sites
qui diffusent des inf fa mais il a
vraiment pas grandchose j'ai pas de truc
systématique comme ça aprèscis tu fais
comment pour t'informer
toi hasardard hasard hasard
j'ai j'ai quelques sites sur lesquels je
m'informe quand vraiment je m'emmerde et
que j'ai que ça à faire type PC impact
Numerama ou le monde voilà mais en fait
il se trouve que 99 % de l'information
dont j'ai besoin mais apporté par les
gens c'est j'ai j'ai choisi tu as
construit ton précisément qui je follow
sur Twitter et je follow pas les gens
qui disent des trucs rigolos je follow
les gens qui disent des trucs
intéressant et donc je dois je ne dois
suivre qu'une centaine de personnes ce
qui est pas beaucoup et quand il y a une
info qui m'intéresse c'est que dans le
panorama de des sujets que j'essaie de
couvrir en général j'ai l'infos sur
Twitter très vite donc je je m'informe
beaucoup plus par les réseau que par un
point central la gouvernance d'Internet
ah la gouvernance d'Internet ça c'est un
sujet rigolo c'est bien parce que ça
veut rien
dire c'est c'est un des
problèmes tu parle de gouvernance quand
tu as un organisme structuré internet
n'est pas un organisme structuré c'est
un peu comme si tu voulais gouverner une
flaque d'eau quoi tu peux au mieux
essayer de LAAC
comppenir en fait la gouvernance
d'Internet on met souvent des idées
assez al compliqué opaque c'est
inaccessible au
profan en gros tu as quelques organismes
américains qui sont chargé de gérer deux
ou trois ressources critiques sur
Internet distribuer les nom de domaines
euh gérer les distributions et les
attributions d'adresse IP
euh gérer voilà deux trois conneries
dans ce goûtl
euh à l'heure actuelle le seul État qui
a un pied là-dedans c'est le le
gouvernement américain par le le
département du Commerce qui a un pied
dans le fonctionnement de ces organismes
là et on nous fait tout un foin du fait
que il faudrait que d'autres que les
États-Unis et un pied là-dedans tout ça
c'est essentiellement de la merde ça
présente pas d'intérêt ça occupe
beaucoup les diplomates parce que ça
leur donne un sujet vachement
intéressant à discuter en anglais dans
des conférences internationales des
sommets et Cera et cetera ça présente
pas d'intérêt
majeur en matière de gouvernance si on
veut essayer de calmer l'omniprésence
américaine il y a essentiellement deux
problèmes autour de ces sujets là et ça
ça se résume à ces deux problèmes l'un
qui est la gestion des nom de domaines
et où ça c'est un pur problème de droit
c'est que le droit applicable en matière
de nom de domaine et le droit américain
euh si tu veux contester un nom de
domaine c'est toujours la justice
américaine qui en dernier ressort
tranchera parce que les les grandes
entreprises qui gèent les les nom
domaines racine le comom le point net et
cetera sont des entreprises
américaines et ça c'est un problème
c'est qu'il y a que la vision américaine
du droit qui prévaut
et la bonne réponse à ça on la connaît
déjà elle est
documentée je te recommande d'aller
regarder ce que fait Louis pousin sur le
sujet par exemple c'est d'avoir
plusieurs racines au système de DNS
d'Internet ça forcera ces racines à
coopérer entre elles et ça rendra le
système beaucoup plus résilient et
beaucoup moins centralisé et le deuxème
problème qui lui est plus vraiment
beaucoup plus
géostratégique c'est l'adressage du
réseau je sais pas si tu sais internet
tel que nous connaissons est
essentiellement adressé par la version 4
duip 4 milliards d'adresses et pas plus
problème niau du nombre et il y a une V6
qui existe qui permet beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'adresse mais qui est pour le moment
très peu utiliséipv6 au niveauipv6 il a
pas des petit problèmes au niveau de
la des comment dire il y a pas de
conflit entre IPv4 et
IPv6 si c'est incompatible l'un avec
l'autre on sait faire des passerell
moins bricolé entre les deux mais ce
sont deux réseaux relativement
incompatibles entre eu il se trouve qu'à
l'heure actuelle la majorité des
équipements savent traiter les deux
protocole sauf on utilise que la version
V4 quel problème ça va poser ça en terme
de géopolitique c'est un truc très
simple il y a plus assez d'adress IPv4
il y a beaucoup d'adress IPv6 ça veut
dire que de plus en plus les les accès
Internet qui vont être fournis seront
fournis sur des adresses IPv6 alors que
les accès serveurs resteront sur des
adress
pv4 ça veut dire qu'on aura créé un
Internet asymétrique un Internet où les
les serveurs sont pas sont pas raccordés
de la même façon que les clien et ça
c'est un problème c'est d'autant plus un
problème que un peu plus de 50 % des
adresses IP sont
américaines les États-Unis consomment 50
% de la ressource alors qu'ils sont 5 %
de la population ça aussi c'est un
problème et donc ça va tendre d'abord à
abîmer internet en le rendant sur un
modèle beaucoup plus proche du Mitel où
les clients et le serveur sont pas sur
un pied
d'égalité mais en plus à faire en sorte
que la concentration aux États-Unis des
serveurs soit accentuée et devienne
structurelle qu'elle soit plus juste un
aléa de la vie économique mais qu'elle
soit dans codée dans la structure du
système et ça c'est un gros gros gros
gros problème donc typiquement les pays
qui se posent des tas de questions sur
la gouvernance d'Internet devrai
réfléchir à
ça c'est pas très compliqué à traiter
techniquement c'est en gros il faut
inciter les les opérateurs d'un peu par
à tout basculé en IPv6 pas que les
abonnements mais aussi les serveurs les
sites les accès et
cetera et en fait si tu veux pour moi
c'est un tandem entre typiquement ce
qu'a fait le Parlement européen sur la
neutralité du Net en forçant les
opérateurs à rester sur un sur un jeu
ouvert et sur un réseau ouvert si ce qui
a été voté au Parlement européen finit
par devenir réellement un règlement
applicable on aura là une première
brique très intéressante et la deuxè et
d'avoir un incitatif très fort à
basculer tout en V6 pas que les
abonnements mais tout et à le faire vite
pour éviter la pénurie qui est en train
de se créer sur V4 et l'espèce
d'économie malsine et
nauséabonde où on vend et achète des
adresses IP ce qui n'a aucun
sens donc là il y a un enjeu de
géopolitique du réseau qui est
extrêmement fort et tu peux être certain
que les derniers qui bougeront pour
qu'on BC tout en V6 sont les Américains
parce que ça leur fait perdre la haute
main qu'ils ont sur le réseau
d'accordgémonie l'égémonie ok on voit on
voit le problème sur d'autres
domaines ça c'est un élément quand on
parle de gouvernance d'Internet faut pas
se tirer sur la nouille pour savoir qui
va rejoindre le bord de Dean à part à la
place du Department of Commerce est-ce
que c'est l'ONU est-ce que c'est
l'UNESCO est-ce que c'est telle agence
internationale de Genève est-ce que
c'est on s'en fout c'est pas ça le sujet
ça ça n'a pas d'importance on peut le
regarder ça occupe les diplomates il
faut laisser un nonos arranger mais le
vrai sujet il est pas là le vrai sujet
il est technique et le vrai sujet
technique c'est comment on fait pour
forcer le réseau à rester ouvert je je
te passe du coocalan tu as commencé ta
phrase en disant c'est comme essayer de
de gouverner une flaque d'eau au mieux
au mieux on peut on peut
l'encadrer c'est ça au mieux on peut
essayer de la
contenir surtout pas la comp est-ce que
tu penses que la loi de programmation
militaire et tout l'arsenal législatif
posé c'est une façon d'essayer de
contenir la FAD sans reprendre le le le
le mot gust Gustave Lebon la psychologie
des foules est-ce que tu penses que la
psychologie des foules a apporté une
flaque d'eau est-ce que l'arsenal
législatif c'est pas un peu une façon de
contenir le peuple et de sa façon
d'accéder à la connaissance
l'article 13article 1 V de la loi de
programmation
militaire c'est en fait une façon
de permettre enfin c'est un outil dont
se dote le pouvoir exécutif pour
surveiller et contrôler la population
c'est très clairement du contrôle social
c'est pas pour traquer les terroristes
c'est pas pour traquer les méchants
pédonazis ça ça se fait dans le code
pénal quand on le fait dans la loi de
programmation militaire pour les
services de renseignement c'est-à-dire
pour les barbouses et qu'on donne en
gros les pleins pouvoirs en matière de
surveillance au barbouses c'est qu'on
essaie de faire une petite NSA à la
française alors nous on fait ça façon pi
niclé parce qu'on a pas les budgets mais
le but est clairement que une forme de
police euh qui est secrète un métier de
roi fait par des Tru puisse surveiller
ce que fait la population en permanence
euh avec un certain nombre de de de
d'Orce à l'état de droit est-ce que ça
t'inquiète quand tu vois
que l'Europe est en train de basculer
dans des gouvernements beaucoup plus
instables que il y a des mouvements
genre occupa Wall Street des mouvs peu
demand des réponses est-ce que tu ça
t'inquiète que ce type de violence
légitime détenu par un état
arrive quand même à passer surtout de la
façon dont ça a été passé bien sûr ça
m'inquiète évidemment que ça
m'inquiète mais je je vois pas de
corrélation immédiate entre les deux
que les politiques qui sont
essentiellement aujourd'hui les tenants
de l'ancien monde aimerait que rien ne
bouge parce qu'ils veulent rester en
haut de la pyramide et c'est même pas
forcément conscient mais du coup ils
font les lois dans ce sens-là donc ils
font des lois visant à contrôler la
population parce qu'ils sentent que la
population s'agite ils font des lois
visant à empêcher internet de déborder
parce qu'ils ne comprennent rien à
internet c'est pas avec des visés
totalitaires je suis pas sûr que ce soit
tout à fait lié à la montée des
totalitarismes la monté des
totalitarismes en Europe elle est
flagrante et elle est plutôt liée à des
questions de macroéconomieque
c'est tu retrouves les mêmes montées de
totalitarisme dans l'Europe des années
30 pour des raisons similaires qui sont
la répartition des richesses produites
qui sont les structures économiques qui
sont bah pour faire simple quand la
finance s'envoie en l'air 5 ans plus
tard le fascisme monte en Europe c'est
comme ça la finance s'est envoyée en
l'air en 2008 le fascisme est en train
de monter en Europe c'est comme ça et
c'est pour les mêmes raisons qu'en 1929
ça n'a pas il y a pas il y a pas de
changement profond euh à l'époque ça
prenait ça prenait des formes très
particulières en Europe
euh mais c'est c'est le même problème
c'est que c'est le le même délire du
capitalisme où on voit les revenus du
capital et donc le prix du capital
augmenter les revenus du travail baissé
la répartition de richesse se faire de
travers
donc en gros tu cherches ce que
détiennent les 10 % les plus riches d'un
pays versus ce que détiennent les 50 %
les plus pauvres et plus les cars
augmentent plus il y a une tension dans
la société cette tension se résout
toujours par le fait que les puissants
qui sont assees voisins des riches ont
envie
que les choses restent stables que le
monde ne change pas et donc font tout
pour empêcher le monde de changer et
créer une tension la tension sociale
devient une tension
politique c'est comme ça qu'on dérive
vers des des systèmes totalitaires et on
voit plusieurs briques en ce moment
c'est oui tu as le CSA qui est une
brique oui tu as la loi de programmation
militaire qui est une brique tu as tout
le mode de régulation de la finance par
contrainte ce qu'on est en train de
faire à la graisse c'est une connerie
voilà tout ça se
tient le fait que les les fachot vont
arrivriver au pouvoir c'est pas une
conséquence d'Internet et c'est pas une
conséquence de la loi de programmation
militaire c'est les deux sont une
conséquence du même phénomène d'une
société qui va
mal
merci tout ça repose sur le principe de
confiance dans les systèmes et le
principe de juste réciprocité mais c'est
évident
que on peut avoir des glissements très
importants c'està-dire qu'il y ait plus
de réciprocité mais on a on a dépassé le
stade de l'écoute c'est ça le problème
c'est plus le service qui va se brancher
sur la ligne et qui va écouter ce qui ce
qui se passe ou qui va même intercepter
ce qui se passe l'air Pino simplefie qui
est terminé voilà là on est dans le
recueil de données s'il y a un doute il
y a pas de doute c'est-à-dire que chaque
fois qu'un trader chaque fois qu'un
directeur chaque rencontré et pratiqué
des des des des décisions contraires à
l'éthique de base d'une maison il était
renvoyé